[Music]
[Laughter]
so
our boy who has just been flinging
[ __ ] at every three-letter agency he can
[ __ ] nuts at this point tucker's that
tucker's that guy in prison that like
it saves all his jug and then just waits
for a guard to come by and it's like
take that mother and you're like god
damn it now they're not going to feed
you for a week
welcome to tucker carlson tonight we're
coming to you live
as we always do live is more fun but
tonight with a special
inside the issues edition of the show
there are an awful lot of issues
and inclusion consultants we weren't
getting more sophisticated surveillance
equipment and more agents in the field
he's talking about in 2015
um they raised the budget for the three
letter agencies
no that money was earmarked for new
platoons of
equity and inclusion consultants and hr
administrators
nice the point of the money was to make
the intelligence community more diverse
less white and less male finally
america's spies
would look different and that is
essential if you want to
to actually we're not sure why it's
essential
what do the race and gender of
intelligence agency employees have to do
with keeping america safe well they
never told us
instead they repeated something that we
had heard once or twice before they said
diversity is our strength
knowing god even one word from her
is is just so ah i
hate this woman i honestly i truly
believe
that their plan was to get her in sooner
but they have to just keep patching up
joe and sticking them out there because
it's like
because she can't even get over with her
own people they know like there's
already people like
higher-ups going like we can't roll this
[ __ ] out they're gonna dude it's gonna
look like cuba in two weeks like
imagine her having to give a speech
every day it would or every a couple of
days
america would start flipping over cars
and just setting [ __ ] on fire
all of us would just be like i hate this
like joe at least just like
like i said before he's like when you
give your kid benadryl when they're
acting up so they sleep a little go to
sleep a little earlier
that's joe joe's just oh we're going to
sit down
and you know meet up with the thing
okay joe but as soon as she's like
we have to me you're like i'm
our diversity is our strength
and our unity is our power
and i say to them our diversity is our
strength
our diversity our patchwork heritage is
not a weakness
it is still and always will be
one of our greatest strengths i thought
it was a nuclear arsenal
but it turned out that diversity
wouldn't be
our strength
next time on arrested development this
is the story of a black president
who undid 200 300 years of greatness in
just
eight years our diversity
is one and then there's just some
cutting that
will earn that playing of obama voter i
made a huge mistake
oh god this is great here i am next to
this woman
who has time and time again undermined
me
and ruined my career but please vote for
her
i wish he was that calm this is the this
is nuts his strengths
our diversity is one of our
greatest strengths i think this is an
opportunity
to establish that out of our diversity
comes enormous
enormous strength how does that work
exactly shut up just read the cliche
it's on the card
whatever it's enormous strength and by
that measure we are now officially
much stronger the office of the director
of national intelligence has just
released
this proof of it it's called the annual
demographic report for fiscal year 2020
hiring and retention of minorities women
and persons with disabilities
in the united states intelligence
community that's the title you're going
to want to get a copy in time for
christmas
not to read it it's not meant to be read
you can smug unreadable
but for the pictures the pictures are
amazing there's one on the screen
we now have conclusive photographic
evidence that our spy
agencies employ several people with
different color skin
there's even a woman in a wheelchair
there's also a man who appears to be
blind
now how do we know he's blind we don't
make assumptions like that
but in this case he's got ray charles
glasses on a cane
and a seeing eye dog
what if he's just a super cool dude with
a dog
and a walking stick but he was a super
cool dude hiking with a dog and a
walking stick
not a walking stick of cane which is
just which
cool covers the glasses and the cane
part
and then he just has a dog with him
maybe maybe he's a cool spot
or how about this they're spies bro
they lie all the time what if he's
pretending to be blind
and the dog's his partner boom and then
like
you feel bad you let the blind guy in
what if he's infiltrating a blind white
nationalist group
huh you ever think about that no you
only think about yourselves
charles glass is on a cane and a seeing
eye dog
that seems like a lot for one man
remember the best spies have a backup
plan
he is
they're gonna kill you tucker he's he's
had it with that man
the best spies have a back-up plan i
like this tucker this this
there's from when we started even since
he was running our show he played a lot
of tucker obviously
he he is you could watch if you watch
from year to year
you could see him giving less and less
[ __ ] it's amazing to watch
i have gone through some phases in my
life where i was at certain jobs or i
was at certain things
and i'd had it right where i i
i had it right and i could
i can always pick up that vibe from
people tucker's [ __ ] had it he's had
it he's just
at this point he's the guy that would
rather collect unemployment and be fired
so it's like you're just coming to
meetings and going no yeah that's a
great idea
why don't we just file chapter 11 now
and [ __ ] save ourselves all some time
and you're going
that's the owner you can't talk to him
like that you're like i don't care
anymore
i don't care fire me i'll take it
everybody when he told judge napolitano
to basically [ __ ] himself
in nicer terms but he worked with him he
was like
[ __ ] this guy too where you can't even
give people the pleasantries anymore
pretending to humor them you're just you
just go right into them
and remember the best spies have a
backup plan
let's say russian assassins come after
our blind intelligence agent as he's
picking up a dead drop of microfilm in a
park in east berlin
somehow they managed to take out his
seeing eye dog maybe with the net
well royce how would you do it
maybe with a net it's a cartoon
i mean it's he's doing it it's effective
he's doing a fantastic job of
underscoring just how ridiculous
everything's become
some kind of net it's okay he can manage
because he still has both the kane
and the ray charles glasses and by the
way we assume that kane shoots
ferrari darts at the ca they think of
everything that's their job
but what is the blind guy's job exactly
he really does have a good point that i
didn't even think of
in that why would you have the dog and
the cane need both
that make that does make me chuckle
good good eye god damn man that got me
uh
exactly what does he do in our fabled
intel community how is he keeping
america safe we don't doubt that he is
but
how well we don't know because the
report doesn't tell us
nor does it explain why there seems to
be some sort of dark halo around the
lower part of the blind man's body in
the picture what
oh i have the answer for that although
photoshop
is that exactly is it spy vapor
[ __ ] spy vapor he really just doesn't
question where all the old people a lot
of americans are pretty old
the intel community says it's diverse so
where are the secret citizens
senior citizens where the 80 year old
super spies
you would hate to think that for all of
its famous sensitivity the biden people
fell prey to
ageism we may need a class-action suit
to sort this out and while we're at it
honestly we didn't see any trans women
non-binary pansexual two-spirits or a
single person from malawi
so that picture which we greeted with
joy
because of its strength is starting to
look problematic
and in fact it is problematic also uh to
the fake spy girl in the middle you
could get it
oh yeah oh yeah according to freelance
intelligence analysis on twitter experts
on digital manipulation
that image the one on your screen is not
real
those people were never in the same room
at the same time
some of them don't even work for the
federal government maybe none of them
the whole thing is a disinformation
campaign it's a soviet style fake
we're serious apparently the american
intel community sen
spent some of its diversity budget not
to achieve diversity
but instead to buy a stock image from
the website
shutterstock the picture you just saw is
entitled quote
portrait of multi-colored cultural
office staff
standing in a lobby oh god you could buy
that picture too you could put on your
next christmas card if you wanted to
maybe you should
how do we have a better photoshop person
than than the [ __ ] national
intelligence agencies do
because everyone hates the national
intelligence agencies
but apparently the stock photo of
multicultural office staff
wasn't multicultural or diverse enough
for the biden people
so they inserted two other stock images
into the picture one of those stock
images is also available on shutterstock
you could buy that for your christmas
card too
it's called quite literally blind young
man with guide dog on white
background which is what it is the other
is entitled again
quite literally beautiful businesswoman
with tablet computer in wheelchair on
white background
i can i i want to you know what i want
to do for a living
i want to be the guy at shutterstock
that name stuff
that sounds like the easiest gig in the
world it sounds like they named it in
chinese and then translated it
you know beautiful business woman in a
wheelchair
huh so those aren't really intel agents
they're stock photographs from the
internet now on one level this is good
news you can make fun of it but
honestly the intel community hasn't
really outed the identity
of its most attractive wheelchair-bound
spy
or it's blind double-oh-seven so they're
safe they're not gonna get nabbed in
that park in east berlin
their identities have still been masked
but there are a lot of other episodes
from this lesson lessons that we
honestly
are ill-equipped to diagnose ourselves
because we haven't thought deeply enough
about it and that's why we are proud
okay that's pretty much the the main
thing i wanted
that man i i mean just the thought
of an undercover like kgb agent throwing
a net
on a person's dog
got him you laugh man but
that's why i think we shouldn't we
shouldn't be sending that blind man out
in the field in the first place
wait a second are you telling me it's a
bad idea to have blind spies
probably i mean unless you're going
undercover as a blind guy